المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع الصينيه تاكه
ان الجيش ارسل سفنا الى السودان امس
الاربعاء لاجلاء الرعايه الصينيين
واشارتا الى ان الوضع الامنيه في السودان
يستمر في التدهور
ان في الاونه الاخيره استمر الوضع الامني
بالسودان في التدهور ولحمايه ارواحي
وممتلكات الصينيين في السودان ارسل الجيش
الصيني سفنا لاجلاء العمال الصينيين من
السودان
مراسله
نرحب بك الى اين وصلت عمليه الاجلاء بحسب
المعلومات على المستويات الرسميه بعد
ارسال الجيش الصيني سفن لاجراء رايه
صباح الخير ازدهار بحسب الجيش الصيني تم
تحريك عدد من السفن العسكريه والحربيه
الصينيه من خليج عدن لتصل الى بورت سودان
ليتم اجلاء عدد من الصينيين بحسب وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه ايضا هنالك نحو 800 شخص
من المواطنين الصينيين المتواجدين
بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وعده مناطق
سودانيه اخرى تم بالفعل العمل على اجلائهم
ونقلهم الى مدينه بورتسودان بهدف اجلائهم
عبر السفن العسكريه خلال هذه الايام يوم
امس اليوم ويوم غد هنالك ايضا اعداد اخرى
من المواطنين الصينيين تصل الى نحو 300
مواطن صيني سيتم اجلؤه عبر المنافذ
الحدوديه البريه للسودان مع الدول
المجاوره الحديث من خلال وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه يؤكد بان هنالك تنسيقا عاليا بين
كافه الدوائر والمؤسسات الحكوميه الصينيه
سواء داخل
الصين او حتى في السفاره الصينيه بالخرطوم
وايضا تنسيق مع السفارات الصينيه في الدول
المجاوره للسودان بهدف ارسال موظفين من
القنصليه والسفارات الصينيه الى النقاط
والمنافذ الحدوديه البريه مع السودان بهدف
التامين السلامه الشخصيه والجسديه للرعايه
الصينيين الذين سيتم نقلهم الى الدول
المجاوره ثم تامين نقلهم جوا بهدف اعادتهم
الى الاراضي الصينيه وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ايضا تتحدث عن ان اعداد الصينيين
الذين تم اجلائهم ونقلهم بالفعل خلال هذه
الايام سيصل الى 1100 صيني تتحدث ايضا عن
ان الصين لا تقوم فقط
باجلاء الصينيين فقط بل هنالك ايضا عمل
وتنسيق على المساعده في اجلاء اعداد اخرى
من الجنسيات الاجنبيه مع الصينيين من خلال
السفن الحربيه والعسكريه الصينيه في بورت
السود على هذه الايام تتحدث ايضا عن ان
هنالك تنسيقا لاجلاء عدد من الصينيين من
هونغ كونغ ايضا خلال هذين اليومين وهنالك
قلق واضح من السلطات الصينيه سواء من خلال
تصريحات المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الصينيه اليوم وايضا تصريحات المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الصينيه على مدار الايام
الماضيه منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات المسلحه
هنالك دعوه رسميه ايضا من الجانب الصيني
ومن وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه لطرفي النزاع
الى وقف التصعيد الوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار والجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات هنالك
ايضا مساءا حثيثه بحسب مكتب الشؤون
القنصليه التابعه لوزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
الى التنسيق كافه الجهود مع السفارات في
الدول المجاوره للسودان بهدف التامين
السلام الشخصيه التي تقول وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه بانها تضعها في المقام الاول لكل
الرعايه الصينيين الموجودين داخل السودان
هنالك ايضا
بحسب وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه الى نقل
الصينيين الذين يتواجدون في مناطق قريبه
جدا من مناطق الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع الى مناطق
اكثر امنا ثم اجلائهم سواء عن طريق البحر
او عن طريق الجو من خلال الدول المجاوره
للسودان مثل مصر اوتشادو وغيرها من الدول
وبالتالي هنالك تظافر لكافه الجهود على
جميع الاصعده من قبل الصين لاجلاء
الصينيين ووزاره الخارجيه الصينيه تحاول
طمانه عائلات وذوي الرعايه الصينيين بان
هنالك
تاكيدا من الجانب الصيني وسعيا حثيثا
للسلامه الشخصيه والجسديه للصينيين قبل كل
شيء خلال عمليه الاجلاء
شكرا جزيلا لك
مراسله الجزيره من بجين شيماء